-Our first guest tonight is
a very talented actress
and producer.
Her latest project, "Erased:
The Murder of Elma Sands,"
is available now on
Apple Podcasts.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Allison Williams, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you for having me back.
-A lot's changed since
the last time you were --
Arlo -- you have a baby,
who is turning 2 in November.
-Yeah.
-How is it?
-It is so wild.
He's, like, a full --
When I watch baby videos
of him and now, it feels like
I'm watching him trapped
in a body that didn't, like --
didn't perform in the way
that he needed.
-Yeah.
-I watch him, like, make the
sounds that newborns make,
and I'm like, "Oh, my God, he
was trying to tell us so much."
And we didn't know.
We just thought he was, like --
you know, had a dirty diaper
or something, but he was trying
to ask very complex questions.
-Yes. It is funny how
that you can --
You can't think --
You can look backwards.
You can see him now and --
-Yes. You can't project forward.
-You can't project forward,
but you can go,
"Oh, yeah, you were gonna be
this the whole time."
-Yeah, and he is, like,
just consistently that guy.
-Yeah. And now you're
coming up -- It's Halloween,
and you're in that sweet spot
where you still get to
decide the costume.
-We get to decide, which meant
a bear costume on the Internet
that does not in any way
resemble a bear.
-Okay.
-It is a heavily air-quoted
"bear."
It's really just --
It has, like,
a white oval on the stomach and
it's sort of like a puke-brown.
-Uh-huh.
-Happy.
-And was this sort of a
last-minute purchase
that you got such a bad bear?
-You know,
I understand the question
and the spirit
in which it was asked.
I'm so embarrassed to say
it was very premeditated.
And it arrived quite a bit ago,
and I have stuck with it.
There's also a
backup firefighter costume,
because he's very
into firefighting.
-Oh, that's more --
It is, I will say --
-Well, no, let me amend that.
He hasn't put out any fires yet.
-"He's very into firefighting"
is a very funny thing to say
about someone who's not yet 2.
-Yeah.
-You're like, "How often
is he running into fires?"
-Well, here's the --
Yeah, not --
But here's the thing.
He's, like, a busy,
like, working --
I almost said "workingman."
He has that bearing.
He wakes up, like,
already kind of overwhelmed
by all the things he has to do.
He looks outside, he's like,
"Ugh! We have to leaf-blow."
-Okay.
-And I'm like, "Yeah, it's fall.
It's sort of, like, your big
season for the leaf blower.
All summer, we were just
moving the grass around,
but now it's like,
this is the big leagues."
-He's like, "I got to start
setting my alarm earlier.
There's too much --
This day goes by too fast."
-So fast.
-Do you guys dress up,
as parents?
-No. That's a hard "no."
-Yeah.
-I forgot that that was,
like, a thing
until someone asked me
a couple weeks ago.
And I was like, "I can't."
I kind of play, like,
a sophisticated version of
dress-up for a living,
so it's --
-I agree.
-I --
-I also --
-Thank you for agreeing
it's sophisticated.
-Yeah. Well, it's mostly that I
share the reason behind it,
and I've never thought
it was sophisticated,
so I'm jumping on like,
"Yes, yes, yes.
That's what it is."
-Yes, yes, yes. Of course.
-Yeah, when -- Even today,
when adults invite us to a party
and they're like, "And it's,
you know, wear costumes,"
I'm like,
"Or...we have other plans?"
-Or -- Yeah.
I once -- I was Waldo one year,
and that was, like,
a pretty simple --
-That's a good idea.
-That's a good adult costume.
-Yeah. Because people know
what it is,
so you don't have to have,
like, a long conversation.
-Exactly. They can really be,
like, vertical or horizontal.
As long as you have
red and white, like, people --
or glasses --
people just, like, get it.
-When people come up to me
at a party and they're like,
"Do you get it?",
I always want to be like,
"I don't get any of it.
I don't get what
we're even doing here."
-What is this holiday?
-Yeah.
I understood dressing up if,
in return for it,
an old person gave me candy,
but what we're doing now
is beyond me.
-As adults is so true.
-Beyond me.
-And it's cold,
and everyone wants to be sexy.
The other thing is,
when you see it through
a kid's point of view,
it's all so arbitrary.
-Yeah.
-Like, you pass, like, a pumpkin
with a face carved in it,
and I'm like,
"I don't know where to start."
We have all kinds of
plants and gourds around us
that we don't hack away at.
-Yeah.
-And, yet, this particular thing
we've decided we're just
gonna demolish once a year.
It's so strange.
It's like -- And, yeah,
why do people put skeletons --
How do you explain a skeleton?
-I know. That's the thing.
My kids are already asking me
enough questions without more.
-Yes.
-Cool it with
your front-steps skeletons.
-Yeah, they're very elaborate
and, sometimes, music's playing
and they're kind of scary.
-When my kids are like,
"Why is there a skeleton
on the front steps
of that brownstone,"
I'm like,
"Everyone in there died."
-That's a really --
-That's how you know everybody
in that house died and that --
-I love -- You have such
a gentle touch as a dad.
-Yeah. Well, if you don't say it
like a bad thing,
they're just like, "Okay, cool."
If you're not like,
"Everyone in there died."
Then they're like, "Aah!"
But they're like,
"Yeah, everyone in there died
and you're gonna die one day,
too, and it's fine."
-And so am I.
-We're all gonna die.
It's crazy for you
to go to school
thinking you're gonna
live forever.
-Or do anything.
-Assuming you're gonna
live forever.
-I want to ask about
your parents, now grandparents.
-Yes. They are still my parents,
but they have also
become grandparents.
-Yeah. It's really cool
they weren't like --
-They didn't become
my grandparents.
-They're like,
"We have bad news."
-"You don't have parents
anymore. But -- wait."
-"But good news --
we're your new grandparents."
-Yeah. No, they are --
-So, Brian and Jane --
how are they taking to it?
-They're obsessed.
I mean, like,
I don't know how to describe --
-First-timers, right?
-First-timers.
I don't know how to describe
the love because
I've never experienced it,
but they are, like...
[ Laughter ]
-It's true.
-That is not --
-Did you realize?
-No, I did not realize
what I was saying.
-Did you realize you,
all of a sudden, were in therapy
and you forgot
all these people were here?
-Well, I didn't know you had
an audience of just therapists.
-Oh, yeah.
-Very weird choice.
-It's Therapist Wednesday.
-Oh, amazing!
-Yeah.
-Hello.
I meant that I haven't
experienced the love of
a grandparent, as Arlo is
only 2, as is well-established.
So -- But they were like,
"Yeah, I assume
we're gonna be crazy about him."
And then what's happened is
now I get texts that are like,
"I need a hit.
I need a fix.
I'm coming by
just to smell his head"
Or like, "I want to get him out
of the nap to get the breath."
And I'm like, "Okay,
do whatever you need to do."
And they're so great with --
I just am very lucky.
They're very close.
-Have -- What does he call them?
I'm always fascinated by --
-The verdict ended up --
My dad is Bub.
-Oh, that's good.
-Bub. Bub.
-Yep.
-It's, like, short and sweet.
-And then my mom is "J.J."
But Arlo speaks
French and English,
so it's kind of like, "Gi-Gi."
-Oh! That's real good.
-And we don't know
how to spell it.
So he's gonna have to,
like, grow up, start spelling,
and tell us how it's spelled.
-He's gonna
have to reverse-engineer
his baby name for your mother.
-Exactly. Also, for any future
grandchildren, like, sorry.
This is just
the established name.
-Right. The first kid
establishes the name --
-It's a big responsibility.
-Yeah.
So -- 'Cause we call --
My parents are the "pankas"
because before my son could say
"grandpa," he said "panka."
-Aww!
-So now we call them the pankas.
And it's so funny when you say
it in front of other people,
'cause they just assume that,
like, my parents are
like Old World Romanians.
Like, they just,
like, wrap shawls.
They're like,
"We are the Pankas."
I have a bunch of questions
to ask you.
We're gonna be right back
with more from Allison Williams.